US Embassy attacked threatens to draw
the u.s. deeper into the kind of Middle
East conflict that President Trump has
tried to avoid Paula Reid is in West
Palm Beach where the president is on
vacation Paula how was the president
responded to the embassy attack good
morning Jericka President Trump has
warned Iran that any additional attacks
or threats against the US could increase
American involvement in the region
president says he does not want war but
he believes is if this came to conflict
Iran would not last long and as we heard
the u.s. currently has about 5,000
troops in Iraq and 750 soldiers are on
their way to the Middle East and that's
on top of at least a hundred Marines
already flown in from Kuwait the
Pentagon may also send an additional
3,000 troops to the region later this
week but president Trump is reluctant to
be drawn into foreign conflicts he
campaigned on a promise to bring US
troops home and this this might explain
why he responded to North Korea's threat
of a new strategic weapon by giving Kim
Jong Un's some room to back down by
saying that both leaders are just
representing their countries and doing
what they have to do but the timing of
these events is significant our
adversaries know that President Trump is
vulnerable he's facing impeachment at
later this year
re-election where any foreign conflicts
especially in the Middle East could cost
him
Anthony Paula thank you
you